you know I need to ask you about
Deadpool because I don't know I'm kind
of looking forward to it
um I have two questions for you uh that
I hope you can answer I heard you start
filming in April is that true
uh I don't know
so you don't have a start date yet
uh start dates are negotiable
you got it okay the other thing uh I am
stunned like the rest of the planet that
you got you to come back and I'm just
curious if you could talk a little bit
about what it was like those initial
conversations with him and sort of you
know like what was it like you
mentioning to him hey do you actually
want to come back and do this and what
it was like you know those that kind of
yeah I think you're giving me too much
credit I I didn't I don't I don't
believe that I'm responsible for Hugh
coming back I I always wanted you to
come back my first meeting with Kevin
feige uh when Disney bought Fox years
ago maybe three years ago or three and a
half four years ago I'm not sure uh was
was about doing a a movie with the two
of us uh a a Deadpool Wolverine movie
um and that was not possible at the time
um and then you know Hugh just happened
to call at that perfect moment and
expressed that he'd be interested in
coming back
um and doing this one more time and and
the contents of that conversation I'll
I'll let you because I I know it's only
inevitable that you and he were going to
speak at some point soon I'm sure I'll
let you answer that
um on his own but but he expressed
interest in coming back and then it was
my job to take that to Kevin feige one
more time and sell it and um it's not
like adding Hugh Jackman to a movie like
this is a hard sell it's a it's an
immediate and emphatic unqualified yes
uh it's just it's a lot of moving parts
and you know Fox and X-Men and all that
kind of stuff that uh uh that Marvel
needs to sort through a lot of red tape
in order to make that happen and they
did it you know and I'm really grateful
that they did it because for me working
with Hugh is a dream come true but
working with Logan and having Logan and
Wade together in a movie is is beyond
any dream I would ever be audacious
enough to have so I'm I'm really really
super [ __ ] excited to do this uh film